how about having ramen in a while I've
just been doing my workouts at a box and
burn with Glen I was like you know what
my knee feels all right
I wouldn't saw that therapist help my
knee I'm all right
started riding yesterday that's good for
6:00 I'm like you know what I think I'm
fully recovered I'm gonna for a long old
job now 1 for that long jog look click
click later in the knee see I'm glad to
hear that only because I like that I'm
not the only idiot so I'm 50 and I hurt
my back why I decided you know Brian
gonna box then play tennis and then just
practice little golfing just move around
my daddy wrestled with me well no no it
wasn't even that my back was like it's
tight I can't figure it out you know
what I'll do a box with Wayne again dad
it enter that and let me twist real hard
yeah I'll keep twisting real hard oh
there it is I feel that little tiny like
a little like you try to ignore it
you're like I'm gonna ignore him but
it's just like that well my back seizes
the [ __ ] up I can't really lift my left
leg to tie my shoe I'm like oh
something's going on here
yeah whatever I let it relax and let it
starts getting better I'm like you know
what it's a little better
there's nothing better there's nothing
you want to do more when your back
starts to feel a little better than
warming up a little and since I'm
feeling so good right now
I'm gonna do some deadlifting because
I've earned it that's smart that's just
stupid be back straight keep it back so
good I'm keeping my back straight no
problem I'm back I'm dead lifting not a
lot I'm not you I'm dead lifting maybe
150 or something just to warm it up well
as I deadlifts as I'm leaving as I'm
putting it down my wife walks in to the
garage startles me a little bit yank my
back goes geek and I just around your
back yep and now today it's better is it
better yes to me flying the plane today
I'm good
sitting for this particular thing for
whatever reason helps me TMZ interviewed
Chuck Liddell and Chuck said yeah a good
return fight would be jail because you
know he's easy no I don't know what do
you mean no
he said perfect warm-up fight for his
comeback so chills like dude I told you
I would fight you
fight you so this is what I get called
out on TMZ I don't know if it's a cop
but I'm using that term Chuck Liddell
said no so much ale said about Chuck
Chael Sonnen would be a perfect warm-up
fight first comeback timsy got ahold of
me to respond I never missed big media
opportunities and TMZ is huge but this
one I just sat it out for first time
ever I told TMZ I'm past my memory
because I didn't know what to say and I
still don't other than I will fight you
right now Chuck he's starting to gain
steam again oh god I just saw you chuck
with uh Brian and I and Ryan had a show
at this comedy store and chuck was there
I saw him he was there with Russell
Peters did you guys talk about it now
no I mean Brian jacked him off cuz
whenever sees a fighter he [ __ ] gets
a hard-on me Rogan and daliyah like
snuck out the back I love Chuck that I
just I don't want talk about fighting
right then yeah I'm gonna watch it I
worked with a couple moms a couple one
two moms and you're just out wildcard
West all the time no I was at today I
was training at fortune I [ __ ] love
Justin yeah yeah he's doing well he's
had two babies tell me so what's up yeah
well he's the bass a good boy how old is
Justin he's 50 okay
he just had twins he had a boy a girl a
guy a guy I met he was almost dead
he was almost dead because cancer please
Lee looks great now but he was in manis
corner in Australia he's always a
managed he's made us conditioning good
for a while he went away from man and
man he wasn't doing so well made in do
that's right
so he had a what kind of cancer he had
thrown it broke it he had like stage 4
throat cancer
they had to take his arm off to put it
on and he's a I love he's one of my
favorite people Northey the toughest guy
I know maybe the toughest guy hop to
Lennox he's five eight fault Lennox
Lewis a maybe five hundred yeah maybe
he's got a hand like this one of the
toughest guys I know a week after he got
out of the hospital chemotherapy the
whole thing I mean Canton talk nothing
he's on the treadmill you may eat the
top top two toughest people in the world
I've ever met yeah like Oh God
um your foxhole oh there's an honor he's
macho let it grow like real guy yeah
he's the type you know what sit you in
the corner make you face the wall like
he would you're not
last we're st. for
last week he's training me he's he's uh
he's in the ring with somebody he's got
his gloves on and and headgear and think
there's a big guy he's training and so
the guy wants to do a little light work
and and so Justin says to him listen
this is light work don't get carried
away with yourself right so the guy
smacks him Justin punches him right well
the right right cross hitch Justin
Justin
boom left through the butler to the kick
to the liver
this guy's like six four for a second he
looked at Justin and then he crumbled it
to the mat when he ran back down it came
to anyway and Justin said to him Oh mate
I [ __ ] told you go easy